es una red interbancaria mundial que
ahora se utiliza como arma financiera
para sancionar a rusia el sistema swift
fundado en 1973 y con sede en bélgica es
un engranaje discreto pero esencial en
la banca internacional organizada en
forma de cooperativas de bancos la
empresa está especialmente centrada en
el origen del código beach que permite
identificar a un banco con un código
único swift agrupa a unas once mil
entidades bancarias e infraestructuras
de mercado para 40 millones de
transacciones diarias en más de 200
países y territorios
las potencias occidentales han acordado
excluir a varios bancos rusos de este
sistema en otras palabras se les
prohibirá a recibir o emitir pagos a
través de este canal el objetivo es
paralizar la economía rusa taxio esta
medida impedirá a los bancos realizar la
mayoría de sus transacciones financieras
globales como resultado las
exportaciones importaciones rusas
estarán bloqueadas
todas estas medidas debilitan
significativamente la capacidad de putin
para financiar su guerra degradará en
gradualmente su economía cada día son
economía
pero la economía europea también podría
verse perjudicada rusia es el quinto
socio comercial de la unión actualmente
le suministra el 40% del gas el otro
temor en occidente es que moscú acabe
creando su propia red interbancaria
el problema al que se enfrenta la unión
europea y también en eeuu es que rusia
está desarrollando su propio sistema
interbancario en paralelo si se excluye
a rusia de swift simplemente
desarrollará el suyo propio con china en
competencia con el sistema swift hasta
suerte hasta ahora sólo irán golpeado
por una serie de sanciones de eeuu en
2019 ha tenido algunos de sus bancos
suspendidos de la red la república
islámica estuvo incluso desconectada de
swift de 2012 a 2016